well should Christians celebrate
Halloween some believe it can be taken
back like other holidays but a former
Satanist who is now a pastor says no
Christians should not celebrate it I
recently caught it with John Ramirez and
he had a strong warning for believers
tell us a little bit about where you
were in relation to Satanism and
worshipping the devil well in 25 years
eight years a boy little boy a years old
demon Church learned being trained by
high ranked devil worship at warlock and
spiritual witches turning me to know how
to take over territory demanded demanded
contract demand different demon
territory demons principalities first
second heaven I was being trained all
the way to the age of 35 sold my soul to
the devil got married Halloween had a
demonic wedding Halloween i baptize my
daughter to the dark side at age 11 so
that was my whole entire life I mean I I
breathe ate and slept witchcraft as for
projecting I were asked to project or
regionally my body I should project
curse the region because if I can curse
the region I can capture the people
knowing what you came from and what you
used to do you're pretty discouraged
that you see Christians celebrating
Halloween why I don't know how you can
cheat on God I don't know how you can
cheat on the Lord Jesus Christ because I
don't see Satan is coming on Good Friday
and come and hanging out with us right
you know I come having Halloween you had
a demonic wedding why would you put your
kids your family what would you put your
purpose your destiny what would you put
your whole eternity in a demonic all
eternity well people say it's just fun
candy kids are having costumes on well
what you see it's much more the candy
you know III said I never said this
before but this can the people from
different walks of life pray over these
candies witchcraft they pair with the
candies you're not going people do you
don't know the person they do not even
know she's a witch okay you don't know
she's a witch she's doing Wicca she's
practicing New Age and you're not gonna
door and you come in you coming in in
legal rights of this witch or this wall
this person is practicing this stuff
giving you this kind of candy
now you taking that stuff home you put
that stuff into your body man and on top
of that in top of that I'm tunnel vein
say out of his mouth you know he's
on Easter he will do with the ruler of
the Church of singing right out of his
mouth he said I want to thank every
Christian parent for allowing their
child to celebrate Halloween one time of
year the devil's holiday and he took
Adam and Eve to lose everything
because of one mistake he told Esau once
one circumstance to lose his birth
rights yeah right so why would you why
would you bring that kind of curse into
your house and curse your family from
three to four generations so when your
kids is five and you think is cool you
dress them up once you put a costume on
someone did the trick of Adam and Eve in
the Garden of Eden they were made in the
image of God they were made in God's
perfect image right the devil tricked
them was sin and changed identity and
once you put the costume on the cattle
can you dress him up as Noah I don't
care me dressing my pastor Abraham once
you put this custom on Halloween the
birthright of Halloween you're changing
your kid's identity that purpose that
the destiny has been canceled unless you
renounce it and bring it back
Wow that is the trick of the devil yeah
now that you're sharing and you share
this everywhere you go everywhere I go
I'm not afraid I'm Emily I'm not
politically correct I'd rather be right
with God you'd be mad with me but Allie
should make heaven yes you know I mean
church is some time to get mad they get
mad with me they get it why are you
saying that why are you talking that way
but wow should I talk if I add my God
told me to speak the truth you know I'm
just a mailman amen
now that you're a Christian you're
actually a minister of the gospel yes
you say that you're now in a season
we're in your life what you're saying I
want to pay the enemy back for all the
25 years and plus you know I've gone to
places that people manifest the
manifestations of demon people casting
out demons here and healing the people I
mean I'm living in the place today I
have to church to the book of Acts that
powerful church that church it came out
of the Upper Room you know that's why
I'm living people saying sir I was just
talking to another sister I was saying
there's Muslim lady came up to the
authors you have forged a character
she's a Muslim she renounced islam she
renounced the situation she accepted
Jesus she went to the doctor no trace of
cancer that's the God that I know that
is the Jesus Christ I know the same
yesterday today and forever more these
people that come from the occult
practices you know I've been in their
coat I do weed you boy
I did this i i i i i did i I practice
what I practice New Age you know
manifestation people set free and you
see the transformation a phrase you see
the love of Jesus Christ wrap around oh
I mean how much that is priceless I
don't mind paying the price I'm gonna do
that and to God call me home and when I
leave my sister listen to me carefully
when I leave this world
I'll make Jesus Christ proud man you
have a would rejoice he'll will rejoice
because I left the battlefield I play
for keeps
I play for keep you did um a perm that's
right thank you so much god bless you
pleasure